pourquoi personne me croit quand je dis que j ai coucher avec Jessica alba
POURQUOI
c est vrai techniquement je suis un prince
mais on peut dire que je suis le king de ces dame parce que je les ai tout eu
j ai "embrasser cendrillon"
ciana je l ai bien bien embrasser
drraaa
mc woodie made in china représente les cartier far-west
et buzz le mongolien tous ce que tu veut faire c est le buz
Buzzz
tu me clash
mais apprends a parler moi j ai plus de 20 phrase digitaliser
Looser
mon plastique a moi c est du béton
et toi tu est rembourré avec du cotons
moi ce qui m énerve chuut
ces les chats TAIS TOI
ces les chats invisible qui parle TU TE TAIS TU TE TAIS !!!!!!
c est pas normal
le problème avec les adulte c est qui on la memoire courte et pas d humours
Vous les jeunes avec vos blague pipi caca vous êtes ridicule
il y a des blague sur nitch  beaucoup plus hilarant
hum hum hum
j ai embrasser la petite sirène mais le j ai fais que de l embrasser parce que les filles qui on des queue j aime pas trop.....
buzz buzz l abeille sa fait bzz bzz
c est pareille moi j ai pas peur de toi
t es missile son en plastique
buzz buzz l abeille sa fait bzz bzz
c est pareille ta des moulures sous les bras et croit moi c est pathétique
vas y mec me parle pas vers l'infini et au dela
buzz... buzz bubububuubuzzz buzz
la belle au bois dormant c étais pendant quelle dormais
mais tu dort
paaa
comme un prince
lapin
petit lapin petit lapin
LAPIN !!
j ai embrasse blanche neige
j ai embrasse aladin
excuser moi c est keny west qui m envoie les photo du cul a kim
il est con
il est sur la plage
on est trop pote avec keny
et d ailleurs j ai cru un moment que sa allais partire en tri somme avec yassmine mais malheureusement
je t ai attraper petit lapin tu tue le temps tu mange mon âme meurs meurs meurs abonne toi a ma chaîne meurs meurs meurs lache t es comme meurs meurs
et sa vous énerve pas quand votre empire est racheter par une petite souris
et gepetto j ai pété gepetto j ai pété rime riche